i'm all in on bow nickel i've never been  more excited about a guy since here in  pico  no i understand like you you want me to  succeed yeah i think he's gonna want him  i just want to chill a little bit no i  get it i get it it's like when you draft  a quarterback in the first round and you  know you play for [ __ ] until yeah  it's like  i'd rather my guy like if it was my son  i'd rather him go to like you know i'd  rather go to green bay and sit behind  aaron rodgers for four years pick up the  skills and then because you know it's  such a short window you talk to the guys  at att though like those behind the  scenes conversations  talk to jorge talk to whoever and  they're like no like legit his his  striking he just hasn't had a chance to  show it see that's what gets me excited